have you ever had someone bring up the
topic of race and diversity within our
personal or a professional setting and
you know how you start to get that that
heart flutter you start to wonder what
it have to defend myself or my friends
what is it what is it that this person
is about to say what are their opinions
on race and diversity is this person
racist
did they vote for Donald Trump these are
the sorts of thoughts that flow through
our minds when the topic of race and
diversity is brought up whether it be in
a personal or professional setting and
can I get a show of hands from anyone
that gets a bit uncomfortable when
talking about racial diversity whether
it be personal or in a professional
setting it's totally fine like you get
the hands up like I also have a
confession I too get pretty
uncomfortable when talking about racial
diversity whether it be a personal or a
professional setting
in all honesty and you know I start to
wonder those what-ifs like what if I
have to defend my right to exist within
the tech industry to this person that
I'm talking to and I say all that to say
this if the topic of talking about race
and diversity makes you uncomfortable as
someone once told me please get
comfortable being uncomfortable at least
for the duration of this talk my name is
Byron Wood fort I've been in the
software industry for about three years
now developing software professionally
for just over two years and in that time
I've learned a lot about the tech
industry and you might be asking
yourself who was this guy
how did he get up here and to answer
that question I essentially have to
explain where I came from in order to
explain how it is that I got up here to
be speaking in front of you at my
favorite software developer conference
of all time strange Lou
I'm from Chicago born and raised and
while this picture might be an area of
Chicago that a lot of people are
familiar with this wasn't the Chicago
that I was most familiar with growing up
the Chicago that I was most familiar
with growing up was a little further
south of
this picture was taken the Chicago that
I was most familiar with growing up is
where the original Regal theater was
built on 79th Street the Chicago that I
was from growing up is where we would go
outside after school to play basketball
and football at a Kurosawa park in Jesse
Owens Park Chicago that I was most
familiar with growing up was the Chicago
work communities would come together and
band together to actually combat the
violence that would happen within their
streets in their neighborhoods on a
daily basis and because of where we
lived if you know my mom my mom was a
bit overprotective well mom always
looked for ways to keep us confined
inside the house and keep us entertained
she didn't really want us going outside
too often and for obvious reasons we
were on the south side of Chicago after
all and as a result my mom purchased us
my first computer when I was about 12
years old and if anyone who remembers
this piece this compact presario desktop
this was my mom's way of keeping us in
the house more often and I remember the
day she brought it home I wanted to
learn everything there was to learn
about it I wanted to learn the ins and
out I wanted to break it down I wanted
to put it back together I want us to
learn about the software that ran on
this thing so I use it every day after
school whenever I could and at the time
we couldn't really afford the internet
so huge shout out to AOL for public for
providing these this they would drop
these off in our mailbox and these
things were like gold to me like people
would saw small ways I was like what are
you doing like give me those like it
uses as many of those as I can I got
free internet you know so but fast
forward a few more years I found myself
in high school and towards the back end
of my quote/unquote career in high
school and I had this hobby in tech and
I just wasn't quite sure what exactly to
do with that hobby right and I wasn't
sure how to translate that into going
into a professional field whatsoever so
because of that I pretty much looked
around and I was like hey what's
everyone else doing post high school and
some of my friends were going to college
so I said heck why not I'll give this
costing a try see how it goes
and college was a bit of a blur
I don't remember a whole lot about what
it was that I was taught when I was
actually in college unfortunately and
because of that the inevitable happened
I actually ended up dropping out of
college due to a lack of interest as
well as lack of funds and I wanted to
and I knew at the time that I dropped
out that I wanted to pursue a career in
the tech industry I just honestly had no
idea how to go about it and where does
every college dropout go who wants to
break into the tech industry anyone yeah
you guessed it Best Buy obviously right
so I worked there for like a year or two
and one day I came to the realization
that this wasn't the place where I
wanted to spend the rest of my life I
realized this would so with that
realization I began my journey to break
into the tech industry I began
researching tech careers and I landed on
the career of a software developer and I
remember thinking in myself back in the
day I used to be really good at
designing my space layouts so becoming a
software developer should be pretty easy
right so I started learning via
different websites such as code Academy
w3schools
and eventually I realized this is going
to be much harder than I thought it was
gonna be originally so I began reaching
out to friends to see if there was
anyone that I knew that knew someone
that was in the tech industry if I knew
someone that was at a tech industry and
it was a software developer and I
completely forgotten talking to one of
my friends and passing that he had told
me that he was a software developer you
know you asked someone what they do for
a living and it goes one ear and out the
other and that's exactly our
conversation took place but anyway so my
buddy Dave and I we chatted for a while
I was asking him questions about
software development and what it meant
to be a software developer and in doing
so I was looking for resources and I
noticed something day as I kept asking
these questions
Dave kept answering and I was like if
he's gonna keep answering my questions
I'm gonna keep
asking them and eventually they've
realized that I wasn't going away so he
invited me out to software-development
meet up at a company known as eighth
light and it told me if you want to
learn about software development we have
open meetups fridays with my company at
eighth light in chicago so I was like
cool so I came out safe light and this
is my first time experiencing a software
development meet up I had no clue these
things existed so my mind was kind of
blown at the time and then after the
meetup Dave and I talked and he asked me
if I'd be interested in going through an
apprenticeship with him as my mentor
whereas he was gonna help teach me
software development and I was like okay
Byron play it cool like no no let him
know exactly what's going through your
mind don't let him know that you're
desperate to leave your job at Best Buy
all right so I put on my poker face and
I was like sure I'll do this software
apprenticeship thing so and to explain
what apprenticeship is if you want to
become a professional software developer
for the company known as a flight
everyone has to go through some form of
apprenticeship and it looks different
from four people with different levels
of experience and it also looks
different from when I started when I
started there were student resident and
then you become a professional dev and
that's pretty much how things were at
the time and of course my first thought
was all right Dave like how much is this
gonna cost
and that's when they've informed me that
a flight was gonna pay me to learn about
software development and I was like okay
sure that sounds kind of sketchy but I'm
down for I'm like Dave's my buddy I
trust them like I'm really high for this
apprenticeship so he could have told me
whatever and now I believe them so and I
remember going home to my parents and I
was like hey mom hey Dad I'm about to
quit my job at Best Buy in like pursue
this software development thing and
become an apprentice at this company and
at the end of my apprenticeship I might
get a job as a software developer and my
parents didn't exactly echo my same
exact sentiments in
excitement like and like at the time
when I like went to tell them like they
were like ya know keep your day job and
you would have thought that I came home
and I said hey mommy dad I'm about to
pursue my career as a rapper and I'm
gonna drop one of the most fire mixtapes
you ever heard and you have to
understand my family doesn't come from a
technical background nor do they come
from a college background so they knew
what they knew and they wanted to wanted
me to go with something they were more
comfortable and more informed on right
like my dad was a military man so he
wanted me to join the military my mom I
was like hey you become a doctor because
you know why not they make a lot of
money you know so and in short that's
how I became a software developer and
then going through my apprenticeship it
was easily one of the most difficult
things I've ever had to do in my life
but it was equally rewarding and
sometime around the time that I finished
my apprenticeship I remember I was
having a discussion with a colleague and
we were talking about race relations
within the country and during our
discussion my colleague asked me he said
why aren't more black people successful
like yourself and they're wondering like
right like you grew up in a not-so-great
neighborhood like you made something
here for yourself like why aren't more
people like you doing the same and I had
to explain to my colleague that there
were a lot of people that I grew up
though grew up with that simply had
things of which or that I had I had
things of which a lot of people that I
grew up with simply did not and after
that conversation with my colleague that
helped lead to the inspiration for this
talk after our conversation I wanted to
pinpoint exactly what it was that I had
that helped me succeed so that hopefully
I could help others like me achieve some
sliver of success in the tech industry
as well and as a result I asked myself
this question where is the gap for
minorities in the tech industry and how
can I help close it similar to my
colleague many people wonder why
minorities aren't succeeding at their
respective companies people wonder
what's preventing us from breaking that
barrier that exists between us in the
tech industry and once we're here what's
preventing us from becoming software
uppers or becoming team leads or
becoming executives within our
respective companies and in asking
myself this question I realized where
one of the biggest turning points came
for me personally and how I was able to
achieve some sliver of success in the
tech industry I realized the solutions
to break in the barrier from minorities
in tech is providing a strong network of
mentors to support them and now you
might be thinking to yourself well my
company hired minorities and they still
left or my company hire minorities and
they're unhappy or my company hired
minorities and they were unable to climb
up the corporate ladder and there's a
number of reasons for that and we're
gonna touch on one of those reasons
today for years our industry has been
mentoring everyone the same as the next
person for years our industry has been
doing instructional mentoring without
conforming to the you to the needs of
the unique individuals in which were
mentoring for years we've been deaf
typing our junior level developers
expecting to get the same results that
we got from everyone else and while duck
typing may be a concept that we
regularly use in software development
you simply cannot Duck type people we
can't X we can't expect everyone to
conform to the same exact type of
mentoring and a huge contributing factor
as to why you'll get minorities that
leave their respective companies is due
to the fact that you're mentoring them
the same as you've mentored everyone
else in previous years and if you
haven't noticed I look different from a
lot of people in a software development
industry and because of that I guarantee
you you and I have experienced life in
completely different ways so why exactly
would you teach me the same way that you
were taught slowly but surely more
people like me are breaking into the
tech industry and it's causing the
makeup of our industry to change and as
our industry changes we need to be able
to change with it and that means
changing the way in which we mentor
mentors must be willing to adapt and
adjust to the uniqueness that comes with
mentoring someone who is a minority
making ourselves aware of the challenges
that my note that minorities face in
tech on a daily basis and the challenges
you may face when mentoring them
one of the challenges our industry is
currently faced with it's currently
faced with is figuring out employee
retention before we look at retention
we're going to take a look at the
current employment numbers for five of
the biggest software development
companies in the industry currently
industries such as our companies such as
Intel Apple Google Facebook and
Microsoft so take let's take a look at
the numbers for people who identify as
mel people who identify as female white
black Hispanic and other and as you can
see these numbers are pretty alarming
and if we look at how likely you are to
keep your job given the possibility that
say you're a dual minority for example
if you're white you're just below four
percent likely to quit your job black
and Hispanic is just below five percent
and what happens if you are an actual
dual minority say you're an
african-american woman for example or a
spanic American woman if you're an
african-american woman in corporate
America you're sixty one point twenty
nine percent greater you have a sixteen
at one point nine percent greater chance
to quit your job then someone who is a
white guy or a Hispanic American woman
sixty seven point five percent greater
chance and why is this this is a
question that was proposed to the CEO of
Intel a company who's been one of the
forefront leaders on being public with
their numbers on diversity and making an
effort to improve the to improve
diversity and culture within their
company however they too have had an
issue with retaining African American
employees as well the vp of Intel had
this to say in regards to their
inability to retain minority employees
he said he thinks Africans get African
Americans get frustrated that they're
not progressing faster they aren't
meeting with and being sponsored by the
senior executives at the company
according to research whites and
minorities do not progress up the
corporate ladder at the same pace whites
are more likely to be placed on a fat
tract two executive positions within
their company whereas people of color
became executives much later in their
careers at the same companies minorities
more often than not plateaued in their
careers and got stuck in middle
management and as a result many would
leave their respective companies this
creates a domino effect for newer
employees this leaves no minority
employees for newer employees to look up
to and when researching other potential
places of employment I personally asked
myself how many people at this company
looked like me how many people have
built successful careers at this company
look like me and how many people have
become executives at this company look
like me and it's far too often that they
answer to that question is no one and
this can be disheartening to both junior
and senior level employees however there
are companies who manage to retain
minorities and are able to see them
succeed after the fact so what sets them
apart from the rest
how are some minorities breaking that
upper management barrier at companies
and being retained over time what keeps
me or any other minority for the example
for what keeps me or any other minority
motivated to take advantage of greater
opportunities within the tech industry
and in asking myself this question I
came across a study conducted on the
career progression of whites vs.
minorities up the corporate ladder one
of the conclusions of the study found
that whites are more likely to be placed
on a fast track to executive positions
positions within their company and as
for people of color they held metal
middle management positions much longer
than their white colleagues so White's
would essentially be fast-tracked
whereas people of color would plateau in
their careers and get stuck in middle
management and while this was the case
at these companies whereas minorities
were successful while people of color
weren't fast-tracked to it these
executive positions their mentors
invested in them as if they would be
their mentors continued pouring into
them preparing them for breaking that
upper management barrier and in turn
this help prevent lowering work
performance and increased chances at
employee retention this is my first
mentor a guy by the name of Dave Moore
David mentored me individually for
several months and eventually David
introduced me to Malcolm as my co mentor
and about four months into my
apprenticeship Dave introduced me to
this guy guy by the name of Paul Pagal
and I remember a conversation Dave and I
had he said Byron do you know what scope
is in Ruby and at the time I was still
pretty new to software development in
general and I was new to Ruby so I said
no I don't know what scope is in Ruby he
said awesome cuz I set up a one-on-one
with you and the CEO of the company he's
gonna explain to you what scope is and
Ruby and I was like what like okay
like to see your company who's gonna
like talk to me and explain to me
software development like that's crazy
alright you know so and with that Dave
also introduced me to a lot of other
people at the company of a flight people
who I generally wouldn't have had the
courage to introduce myself to in the
first place and with that it helped
build my courage up to introduce myself
to people that were also outside of a
flight and thus growing my network of
mentors so to be completely successful
as mentors we must be aware of the
challenges that we may face when
mentoring someone who is a minority
we're presented with challenges that
just hasn't been the norm for our
industry in previous years and because
of that we need to adjust according to
research minorities who plateaued in
their careers receive mentoring that was
basically instructional was the most
successful minorities enjoyed closer
fuller developmental relationships with
their mentors so purely instructional
mentoring wasn't sufficient enough
apprentices needed to fill connect it to
their mentors
research shows that cross race as well
as cross gender relationships can have
difficulty forming nevertheless mentor
ships must often be cross race or cross
gender and as a result you have the
possibility of situations such as
negative stereotypes mince words must be
willing to give their apprentices the
benefit of the doubt in
vesting in them because we expect them
to succeed a potential mentor who
withholds the a potential mentor who
holds a negative stereotype perhaps
based on race might withhold that
support for his apprentice his or her
apprentice until they've proven
themselves worthy such subtle racism as
that may help explain why none of the
minority professionals in the research
that I cited earlier were fast-tracked
to executive positions whites were
placed on a fast track based on their
perceived potential whereas people of
color had to display a proven and
sustained record of solid performance
over time in effect people of color had
to be over-prepared before they were
placed on the executive track and I
don't know about you but I start to get
more reserved in my actions when I'm not
given the benefit of the doubt I started
to take less chances and say a lot less
out of that lack of trust negative
stereotypes have also been proven to
reduce work performance as well which
brings me to the topic of stereotype
threat stereotype threat is when people
feel themselves to be at risk of
conforming to the stereotypes within
their social group and to elaborate on
this psychologist psychologists at
stanford conducted a research study they
placed both men and women of equal level
math skills in a room and they gave them
a standardized math test to take and
even though the men and the women were
of equal level math skills
the women would actually underperform on
the standardized math tests and the
psychologists Jersey had an epiphany
they said they said perhaps what we're
witnessing is the definition of
stereotype threat so they reek inducted
the study they brought the men and women
together in the room once again gave
them the standardized mat test except
this time they did something different
this time before the test started they
stood up in front of the class and they
said you may have heard that women don't
perform as well as men on standardized
math tests however that's not true for
this particular test for this particular
test women actually do as well as the
men
and with those few words they helped
eliminate the underperformance of the
women on the standardized math tests so
just being in an environment where you
believe there's a stereotype can affect
how you perceive yourself sometimes all
apprentices need to be told is that they
can do something to be told that there
is good as everyone else that's around
them and that brings us to another
challenge that you may face when
mentoring someone who is a minority and
that's being a coach and a counselor a
coach gives technical advice while a
counselor talks about the emotional
experience of doing something and offers
that emotional support and I remember
when I had started my apprenticeship at
a flight I walked into work every day
with one goal in mind and that was to
make sure that I didn't get fired all
right like you laugh but that was like
in my mind all the time right like I was
walking into work with this impostor
syndrome I was surrounded by people that
went to school for computer science I
was surrounded by people that had been
in the industry for five ten plus years
by people that just dropped 20 stacks on
dev bootcamp right and I'm like
completely new to software development
and over time this started weighing down
on me and luckily I opened up to my
mentors and not let them know how I felt
and to my surprise my mentor expressed
to me that he felt the same way when he
had started his apprenticeship he
thought everyday that when he walked
into a flight he was also gonna get
fired and this was huge to me because I
knew how much experience he had I knew
he had years of professional experience
before becoming an apprentice so I was
like alright if he felt this way then
maybe I'm doing okay and sure enough my
mentor is rest assured that my
apprenticeship was going rather well
so to be completely effective as mentors
we must play the role of coach and
counselor because too often minorities
feel like outcasts because we feel as if
there's no one at our companies to
relate to and while there may not be
many people at the company that looked
like us that doesn't mean that you as
mentors can't be there to emotionally
support your
prentices through the mentorship process
research shows that apprentices are more
likely to be retained when they felt as
though they could look up to their
mentors close mentoring relationships
are much more likely to form when both
parties see parts of themselves in the
other person the apprentice sees someone
whom he wants to be like in the future
and the mentor sees someone who reminds
himself or herself of themselves years
ago is that stated before my mentor felt
like he'd been in my shoes before he
felt like he wasn't good enough to work
for a flight the same way I did he
thought he was gonna get fired from a
flight in the same way I did we both
went through similar struggles and
feelings of emotion and connected on
that level as I mentioned before many
mentor ships must be cross race or cross
gender and something that many cross
race relationships may suffer from is
something known as protective hesitation
protective hesitation is when you view
your relationship with someone as more
fragile than others in fear that you
might offend that other person out of
something that you do or say out of fear
that they may take it the wrong way in
the case study a white mentor thought is
african-american apprentices style with
too abrasive but he kept that he kept
that filling to himself for fear
sounding prejudice specifically that he
harbored the stereotype that all black
men were rude or disrespectful the
mentor eventually found out that he was
right when his apprentices style became
an issue with other people at the
company as well and at that point his
apprentices his apprentice have been
deemed a problem one that his mentor
could have easily helped him solve had
he had mentioned it earlier and people
believe that we aren't supposed to
discuss race if we have to discuss it
then it must be a problem but
relationships were apprentice and mentor
can openly discuss race can translate in
the greater opportunities for the
apprentice some might argue that having
open discussions about race between
mentors and apprentices might leave the
apprentices filling other but that
doesn't have to be the case when we are
open to discussing race we're helping
inspire people like me to take hold of
things of what makes them unique now
remember a conversation that I had with
one of my mentors he said
Byron I don't know if you realize not a
lot of people in the software
development industry look like you and I
was like okay like like is this guy
making a point and sure enough he was so
he said Byron I don't know if you
realize not a lot of people in the
software development industry look like
you and because of that if you want you
can take your goals of wanting to
actually give talks at conferences to
give workshops to mentor more people and
you can be that person that people like
yourself look up to you can be that
person that introduces more people like
you into the software development
development industry my mentor inspired
me to take hold of something that other
people might use to make them feel other
by openly discussing race with me and
helping me to see an opportunity to
inspire others like myself so we
discussed how white men as well as
people of color have been shown not to
progress up the corporate ladder at the
same pace and how people of color tend
to get stuck in middle management
positions much longer than their white
colleagues we've also taken a look at
the diversity numbers among several of
the big tech name big-name tech
companies and employer retention rates
as well we've learned that we can combat
employer retention through building a
strong network of mentors to support our
minority apprentices we've learned about
being a coach and a counselor for our
prentices we've learned about the
possibilities of negative stereotypes
within the workplace as well as how we
can identify and be role models for our
princesses and we've also learned about
the possibilities of protective
hesitation and I urge you to ask
yourself this question where is the gap
for minorities in tech and how can I
help close it while mentor minorities
closely in improving the way we admit we
mentor is a pretty huge opportunity it
simply is not the end-all there
plenty of other ways for us to improve
diversity with and culture within our
workplace but but a huge opportunity
area that we're missing is creating
Closer fuller developmental
relationships with our apprentices in
growing our apprentices network of
mentors to help ensure that our
apprentices our apprentices succeed as
well if we work on that and we can
continue to ask ourselves this question
on a regular basis I believe we'll see
more people happy at our companies and
be able to attract and retain a lot more
diverse groups at our companies as well
and that's all I have for you today
finished early so I have time for
questions if anyone
I can be a bit more specific when you
say there's a larger cultural opposition
like are you saying that there are
people within the teams not buying into
the okay gotcha right right for sure so
the question was like in regards to
increasing diversity and improving
culture within a workplace on a much
larger scale at larger companies so in
terms of that honestly it comes down to
the upper management right like if upper
management truly believes that
increasing diversity and an inclusion
within a company is important then
they'll make those changes and
essentially get everyone else on board
and if people aren't on board then
perhaps they don't belong at these
companies like and that's honestly the
harsh truth like not in it's like
picking technology at a software
developer one is going to agree what the
software that you decide to pick right
and perhaps like if like whoever decides
hey that software isn't the software for
me maybe they don't belong on that team
and that is the honest harsh truth to
increasing diversity and inclusion sorry
not sorry
[Applause]
well to help with impostor syndrome
well first off right like I had to have
the ability to be open to them and I
didn't really develop that ability to
like be open to them and admit that I
had those thoughts until they like
opened up to me first right so like
opening up that dialog and essentially
like admitting that hey we weren't
perfect when we started out right like I
didn't know any of the stuff that you
know you don't know currently and just
reminding them of that on a regular
basis right so that like is on the
outside looking in when someone's a
beginner they're looking at us like
we're wizards they're just like oh man
like you're like this is magic that
you're doing right now you know and we
have to like keep reminding them that
it's not and they can actually get there
someday but to help with impostor
syndrome another thing that helped me is
actually teaching people that knew less
than I did right so one cool thing
within the culture of my company is that
they would assign us to give talks right
like talks on like scope or like any
other technical topic for that matter
and whether people actually knew about
it or not or like you helped a couple of
people understand something a bit more
in detail right it like gave me that
time to focus and hone in on this one
thing that I could help teach someone so
that was really helpful to me I have I
have the question was have I taken on an
apprentice I've taken on two or three
our first apprentice that I took on and
she's actually in this room it was a
really bad experience I was really bad
giving feedback
I completely forgot how like like
detrimental that was to the
apprenticeship process and how like
fragile we are when actually I given
that feedback so like she had like
opened up to me and like expressed that
and because of that that helped me
become a better mentor and she's one of
my best friends right now so that's
what does 8 light mean that is a good
question and I will answer that for you
oh wait no so eighth light from what I
can recall and probably wrong but it's
on the website there are seven lights
within the ideal the ideals of what we
believe goes into writing clean code and
software and the eighth light is
actually supposed to be you right it's
supposed to be you're essentially like
the most important piece of writing soft
right encoder and writing good software
in the black shirt I got you thanks for
people who whose companies don't have
actual mentorship programs what avenues
should they take honestly just start
mentoring what are they gonna tell you
know right and if they do tell you know
then a like I like that's another
situation whereas hey this might not be
the place for me right like I'd honestly
like start that and if you have like
someone that's more junior come up to
you to say hey like I'm more interested
in learning about XYZ and you can like
go from there
or you could take it upon yourself to
like just say hey if anyone wants to
learn about this list of things then
come to me and like let's have some
one-on-one sessions and start going from
there and that could potentially grow
into something that's a bit more formal
and official within the company so I've
seen it happen before back there
yeah so I was a pretty lengthy so I'll
try to summarize it um the question was
like with me getting my first computer
and that being important to me do I
think that there are ways of which we
can improve the ways in which people
like me when I was a kid to get
technology in their hands such as
Raspberry Pi etc and yeah like we can be
very proactive on that because it's
honestly very important while I didn't
touch opponent in this talk there are a
lot of kids that grow up without
computers but now nowadays there are
more computers in a lot of households
but there's still a lot of kids that
don't have them so having like a chief
computer whereas people can like do some
experimenting with and figure things out
is really huge to a lot of people's
lives and it's just like this area in
which of Technology that a lot of people
that I know from that when I grew up
simply don't know exists right when I
became a software developer people were
like cool like what's that right like
it's completely new so it's really huge
yeah so the question was how did I
connect with mentor and or how did I
connect with my mentor so yeah so like
Dave I had told me like a couple of
times during my apprenticeship that he
saw a lot of traits that were in him
that was in me during my apprenticeship
for one I would not take no for an
answer
like I would continuously found him on
things and because I was working
full-time at BestBuy I had to like still
on days before I became an apprentice
full-time I was coming in there like
every day that I had off and like asking
him to stay with me like extra hours if
he could so he like saw traits in in me
that he saw in himself and I think
that's honestly the most important part
of creating a mentorship or mentor
relationship is actually being able to
identify it with the person that you're
mentoring right without that there will
always be a disconnect in my opinion
does that answer
for sure how do you find people without
mentors Mentors that is a bit more
difficult question but one of the ideas
of which I have is creating a meet-up
specifically I'm planning to create one
for people of color and this meetup is
actually gonna be like a travel meetup
where as we go to these neighborhoods
where there's a larger population of
people of color and actually have like
meetups at a coffee shop etcetera right
because like I said I had no clue
software meetups were a thing until he
had introduced me to them and they
weren't in my neighborhood right like
they weren't like anywhere near where I
was growing up so I think that is the
most vital thing is like putting people
like within the vicinity of having
people that they can meet with and talk
to on a regular basis
yeah yeah so the question was how do
high school counselors like close the
gap for kids to essentially get them
interested in tech yeah so sorry but
like any experience that I've had in
school in terms of like tech was like
way behind all the time right
and it was like bad experiences where I
at one point I was like is this what I
really want to do so with that I would
honestly outsource and find someone who
is actually in the like tech industry
and like say like hey like this is our
curriculum this is what we're doing
is this even relevant right right it or
is it like 5-10 years old and from there
you can create something that is a bit
more up-to-date as well as creating
something that's a bit more interactive
and fun because like all like learning
about technology is cool and all like
that's not the part that's actually the
fun part the fun part is doing okay so
in doing things in like doing things
that are interactive such as like maybe
playing with like a toy robot and like
coding that right there's a different
like toy coding toys of which I can like
give you links to if you want
so how the transition from being a more
informative mentor to becoming a
coaching counselor yeah so like that
goes to what I was mentioning earlier
and that's essentially just like being
open to them right because like in a lot
of mentor a lot of mentor ships actually
begin that way it whereas you're just
being the informative mentor and you're
actually not connecting on that level to
the point that they will open up to you
with like things that they don't know
for example right so just being open and
honest with them
on some of your faults that you like
currently have or have had in the past
just letting them like reminding them
that you don't know everything that you
didn't know everything once upon a time
and letting them know like hey if like
there's anything that you want to like
come to me with like feel free and like
I feel like that can help bridge the gap
there so
I can you repeat that last part what
advice would I give
yeah for sure
I can we talk after that's a that's a
pretty long one yeah anyone else what
are the don'ts for Mentors
mint yeah for sure yeah so if I had a
larger time block I actually wanted to
touch upon that but the don'ts for
mentors in terms of mentoring minorities
or min touring in general both okay cool
I said one of the things of which I
actually used as inspiration for this
talk as I said my mentor inspired me to
like get on stage and like gift talks
right like not all minorities want to do
that like right like not how people of
color want to actually be on stage and
give talks and workshops some of us just
want to be regular developers right so
like you can still inspire them to be
that and do what they actually want to
do without like telling them hey go up
and get into the spotlight and be that
person that everyone looks up to right
like it's fortunate or unfortunate for
me that this is something that I
actually want to do but yeah so that's
why one of the don'ts that I would say
for mentoring someone who is on minority
form or I can talk to you afterwards
it's going to be a long list
yeah so like the question was like where
do you as a mentor draw the line for
when someone says that they can or can't
do something in telling them that they
can actually do it well it like honestly
when you know their ability if you're
working with them closely as a mentor
then you know like where they're at and
essentially like what they can do and if
like you tell them hey like you can
definitely do this and they fail then
that's fine too right like or we're all
learning from failure in like you just
rest assure them that it's all good
but but yeah like most of the time like
just being said like like just the words
of saying like hey like you got this is
huge and that completely changes how a
lot of people think about things so how
much time one one request okay okay
sweet
so was that yeah cool all right if you
have any other questions feel free to
find me I'm always open to discussing
whatever it doesn't have to be mentoring
it can be you know anything
[Applause]